no race was ever won in the first corner
but many have been lost there I should
know I was born to be a race car driver
but there's only one problem
That's not me that's me he picked me out
of a pile of pups a tangled mass of
claws and tails this was definitely this
one the pick of the litter she always
said that well just a minute now
we were thinking of keeping them he
always said that true hey call it fate
call it luck all I knew was I was meant
to be his dog you like that like it I
loved it sound smells I felt like I
truly belonged
in racing your car goes where your eyes
go big kid not really much of a dog
person it's more person than dog Danny
was clearly taken with her grooming she
probably bathed every day for all I knew
does he always stare at people like this
if he likes them the best drivers don't
dwell on the future or the past
the best drivers focus only on the
present
and so
no one knows what curves life will throw
at you
but if a driver has the courage to
create his own conditions and the rain
is simply rain
but for now all I want is one more lap
we're faster Danny pastor
oh boy c'mere it must be amazing to have
a body that can carry an entire creature
inside I just hoped it would look like
me
you